i
en él
quizás con la rutina del trabajo al
suelo
i
o quizás columnas como portera
acabamos todos
en el centro
y lo más probable es reciente
y
pero como los últimos días y policías
la ley funciona correctamente como una
cuenta de ahora
[Música]
para revelar y dejarla de algunos sobre
meses cuando el 29 de julio es el cuerpo
de volar
y empezamos a nosotros
y más
y sorpresivamente
el futuro en el presente que como
sociedad de sacar los recursos en apenas
7 meses aún no puede satisfacer sus
necesidades básicas de higiene alimentos
en mi opinión para explicar el concepto
de saná listening
las necesidades actuales
si entramos al récord de siete meses
estamos viendo sostenibles
es una oportunidad
[Música]
consumir
la economía
y hablamos ahorita
mientras yo
[Música]
la pregunta es entonces cuánto
consumimos y cómo consumir
[Música]
un producto que esto nos conocen
mundialmente
es muy práctico y muy versátil
la
y américa hace que muchos productos más
económicos como unas muletas
sí
origen
por millones de años
millones de mitad del petróleo está
hecho
440 millones de toneladas se producen
cada uno
todos en el aire
mi madre está indicó que existen dos mil
soles
en los 50
donde empezamos a conocer sus materiales
con los que nos hemos salvado muy
familiares las servilletas poner los
vasos cubiertos en parques pañales y
demás y debajo de ella 40 horas la
verdad
de sectores que parten de una esposa con
tiempo libre
entonces no es necesario que no respetan
los límites de recurso naturales porque
la naturaleza no existen desecha porque
empezamos a operar en contra de esa
lógica que hasta la última funcionar y
bueno los peores tiempos ahora hay
lugares muestran proyectar completamente
destinado
al final del partido
ah
ellos madres con el hogar
y ahora productos más complejos y más
elaborados
tales como la ropa los electrónicos
un millón de botellas de plástico
cada amigo
más transparente del clásico que
producimos
en todos los números
[Música]
y para el futuro
lo entendemos y también porque tenemos
recursos
[Música]
y sí
a largo
y
cuando ustedes
o
siempre una pequeña evolución
el ser humano debe ser más evolucionado
porque es porque alguien tira al fuego
la herramienta sin necesidad leyes y
normas y tenemos vientos cumpliendo
sentimientos y voluntaria de más
problemas de imagen
de clásicos
y me pregunto significativamente con
tantas empresas
y aquí
antes también antes de tocarla
y los
en el pánico
más bien yo les traje cuatro pasos de
oliva para que podamos usarlos como toma
de decisiones
y en primera vez informarnos
hoy en día es casi inexcusable decir
tenemos un problema
pero no pensemos que una manera de ser
[Música]
o no
entonces información ya está en la forma
articulada que es documentar esas
películas de postas
hay redes sociales
por qué
y la segunda es información que le hice
a las prácticas y esas cosas
esto es como
el ejemplo que más
de manizales claro que este paso como
muy importante
[Música]
por qué
y ayer
y llegando
[Música]
a ésta
pero
[Música]
yo no soy
pero ahora no
[Música]
dos años
y como de todos porque nosotros además
también está regular
sin embargo y pueden darse cuenta que sí
importan porque hay muchas marcas
entonces usted en línea o una empresa o
trabajo en un lugar donde salen las
cosas para ser mejor puede minimizar los
padres pueden reducir más
el sitio porque eso es donde más
[Música]
luego con patrones
de guía
así
entonces
en ese sentido se puede comunicar y eso
va a sumar más
y bueno
y
él
perfecto
porque a la hora de hacer ustedes por su
día por su planeta por su futuro lo
hicieron
y la segunda es que no piensen eso
[Música]
[Aplausos]